you're in California right now you're in
Palm Springs yeah is that where you hang
out mostly in Palm Springs are you just
visiting no not at all uh my uncle lives
here so we had Thanksgiving here so it's
a big family reunion reunion that's nice
so where do you mostly spend your time
well um
I'm using all jobs
so I was in Antarctica before that and
after
wait a minute so I want to hear about
this because I'm very intrigued by
Antarctica uh what do you do in
Antarctica um I was a janitor on a
research base there at mcmurda so like
the largest base down there there's
about 500 to a thousand people in the
summer about a hundred for the winner oh
my God so it's deserted in the winter
practically yeah and it's dark too
um have you been there during the have
you been there during the winter
no I've got to go
back you're gonna spend a winter
in Antarctica yeah it's gonna get weird
it's gonna be really weird
um and and you're going to be spending
it on a base and all I can think about
is that movie the thing that takes place
I think in Antarctica and uh and and man
is it it's such an intense environment
are you worried about going I mean yes
and no I'm more excited I
I mean I I'm glad I did a summer first
because I don't think you know like it
it's it's a lot it's it's a different
world just tell us what life is like on
the base you're you work as a custodian
is that what you say yes the master of
the custodial Arts yes
yes I mean Antarctica itself is like one
and a half times the size of the US and
there's like about 50 bases about 15
different countries they're all very
very spread out so none of them are you
know you can't like visit any of the
other ones really but McMurdo is the
largest one
um it's American based because they have
a lot of field camps a lot of research
about and about uh but life on the base
is I don't know I mean it's a lot of
work like you're there to work so that's
I guess you're there to work but are you
living in are you living in Barracks are
you living in dorms where are you living
yeah yeah I mean they're they're more or
less dorms uh so like part of the
Antarctic treaty is I leave no Trace so
everything has to be semi-permanent and
then you know not taking up as much
space just for heating purposes I mean I
guess a lot of purpose is just building
as well so yeah kind of like college
style dorms like everyone has a roommate
um and then like bathrooms down the hall
and yeah it's it's very dorm style and
uh how do you do they give you any kind
of testing or psychological testing
because I think I would go insane I'm
pretty certain yeah that if you put me
in the winter in at in Antarctica with
you know 50 other people in dorm style
living I would be the one that snaps and
I would snap very quickly within half an
hour of the helicopter leaving I would
say yeah it would be about half an hour
maybe you know I'm gonna say 35 minutes
yeah you would become the thing I would
be the thing yeah it would be about
Conan going from going from place to
place just doing bids and driving people
crazy affecting people yeah I think
you'd be entertaining at least uh for a
while and then I just uh be crying and
I'd go insane what what do they do to
make sure that you don't lose your mind
no there's a lot of testing uh I mean
and there's it's mostly like Health
testing you know physical like Dental I
think it's a bit of psychological
there's not like you know they're not
showing you the photos of the the
Rorschach blots yeah I think it's it's
you know that's why they want you to do
a summer first when they can't get you
out if you do go a little crazy
um but it's more of the physical
background and stuff they just want to
make sure that you never have to go to a
doctor there's nothing that's like would
be wrong because you would be stuck down
there you know say like a gallbladder
scan or if any like stuff like that
comes up or like your wisdom teeth out
yeah but uh but if something I mean
sometimes things just happen they do
have a way to get you out of there if
they need to right uh I hope so oh yeah
I know it sounds to me don't go
this sounds to me like they can test you
for so much but sometimes things just
happen you know I oh I take care of
myself and I routinely you know you know
take care of my my body and I have
things checked but I'd say about I don't
know every three or four months I have
major organ failure and it's just
something that happens when someone hits
my hair yeah
I'm resuscitated constantly yeah